今年42岁，
然后和前夫分开有六年了，
有一个女儿，
现在是高一，
她是一直跟着我的，
然后今年新村了一个男的，
她比我大12岁，
她54岁，
我是从农村出来的，
现在在新一线城市，
就是家人父母都在这边啊，
他是这边人，
他是今年刚离的婚，
然后就是我们准备再有一个一辈子备领证，
这样子他今年为什么跟他的老婆分开呀，
好像他们之前协议了有一两年了，
然后正式是今年分开，
大概就是说原来的话，
他前期是一个小职员，
现在可能做的比较大，
赚的比较多，
这样子，
然后就比较强势吧，
他是这样跟我讲啊，
然后就是我手上我自己是有一套房子，
认识他的时候我还有贷款30万，
他们家大部分的财产他都分给他前妻了，
他分到了两套，
就是位置不怎么好的房子了，
嗯，
认识我之后，
他卖掉了一套，
现在就是租房子住在我这边我工作的地方，
然后他来付房租生活费什么的啊，
然后就准备在我工作的地方买一套小一点的房子，
他他付首付，
然后我俩一起付按揭这样子，
嗯，
我现在想问的是他一共3套房子，
因为其中一套小房子是他妈妈给他的，
我自己是一套房子，
现在还没有做进去，
跟她收的房就是这套房子，
我嘴巴上是这这样说，
偷这套房子给我女儿，
她也同意的啊，
那我想问一下，
这套房子就是我们领证之前要不要写什么协议呢？
还是觉得不用。
不且你的这套房子算是你的婚前财产，
但是还有30万的贷款，
对不对，
对，
本来是有30万的贷款呀，
因为他比我大嘛，
他自己主动说给我20万的彩礼，
然后我的意思就是说十万十五万就够了，
然后他说就给20万，
然后我就拿着他那20万还掉了那个贷款20万，
然后现在剩下10万，
那我建议你，
你再找个人，
你借10万块钱，
你在领证之前把这10万的贷款也还完，
这样的话没有纠纷，
一套房产就完全变成你的婚前个人财产，
现在自己手上有没有存款，
我手上有二三十万，
但是我纠结两个点，
就是说第一就是把这个放在我自己一张卡上不动，
还是要先给他还掉，
这样子我觉得啊，
就是没有纠纷是最好的，
你心里也踏实，
就是他是10万块钱嘛，
你把这10万块钱一还，
你手上还有个20万的存款，
你就单独放在一张卡里，
这样的话，
房子也是你个人的，
存款也是你个人的，
你将来想给你女儿，
你自己一个人就能做主，
你直接办过户都行啊，
那如果有一天这套房子我到时要拿来卖的话，
或果我还完了的话，
也是给我自己的，
不用写协议是吧，
现在是的，
如果这套房在你领证前，
哪怕领证前一天是吧，
还完了贷款，
没有任何的经济的欠款啊什么的，
那这套房子就是你的婚前的，
个人的，
就完全属于你的一个财产，
将来你想。
要卖这个房子，
你也单独用一张卡，
就不要用你婚后用的那张卡，
你单独用一张卡，
专门用来接这套房子的房款，
那这张卡也别动，
那你就能证明嘛，
对不对，
有打款的记录，
有卖房的合同嘛，
有金额嘛，
能佐证嘛，
证明我这个单独的这张卡里面的钱就是我卖房子的钱，
这个钱还能是你个人的，
好的好的，
那你就不用签协议了，
本来重组家庭相互就不太容易信任对方，
你一跨上来让他签个协议，
他心里膈应你，
对，
就是目前都还挺好的，
他也挺上进的，
就不算差异，
他都不在乎，
因为我是初中生嘛，
然后他是一个硕士生，
这样子啊，
嗯，
但是有一点啊，
就别的意思啊，
就是有一种情况下，
你的这套房会跟你再婚的这个老公产生关系，
如果说你走在前头，
那么这套房就变成了你的遗产，
那他作为你的正当的配偶，
他有继承权的，
你女儿也有继承权，
爸妈也有继承权，
他们来分这套，
那么这么进来是不是我相信份协议会更安脏一点，
你写个遗嘱就可以了，
你写个遗嘱放你女儿手上，
就是说你去世了之后，
这个房子有你的女人个人单独继承，
这样既可以让你以后的老公没有继承权，
也可以让你父母没有继。
权也可以让你的女儿将来的老公没法分这个房哦，
好的好的，
如果说我们买房，
因为她刚刚把那边就是偏远那套房子卖掉了，
就是在我工作的地方，
然后买套房子，
然后我们最近在看房，
房子的话是不是写个份额会好一点，
他也为他说他如果愿意写，
那当然是最好的，
他要是不愿意的话，
咱也不能强求吧，
毕竟是全都是人家出钱，
嗯，
就是他出那个首付，
后续的话就是我一起出那个按揭，
虽然说现在就是租房啊，
什么那个收生房费他出，
但是我差不多也出了一半了，
因为我也是做小生意，
为我们两个的收入差不多这样子，
如果要卖这房，
份额是最好的，
好好，
那就这样，
拜拜。
有个朋友说年纪轻轻写遗嘱就这事儿，
我要跟大家讲一下啊，
老外好像有有这么一个讲究，
反正他们过什么节的时候，
全家人都在写遗嘱，
一年更新遗嘱，
明年写，
我们中国人就老忌讳这个东西，
其实这个东西有一个另外一个说法，
叫平安值，
大家听说过吗？
平安值我感觉我现在就该每年写个遗，
每年写个遗嘱是吧？
我要是噶了的话，
这钱怎么分，
我得照顾这么多人呢？
就是观念的问题啊，
就是当有一天你的观念觉得就是对我的孩子的一种更好的保护的时候，
我是愿意接纳他的。